one of your
quotes that i think of often and i might
be paraphrasing this is if you want to
avoid conflict rule number one is avoid
people who are constantly involved with
conflict right i mean something along
those lines i mean for example when
you're in a relationship just watch how
the other person treats their worst
enemy because eventually they'll just
redefine you as enemy and you'll get to
feel that behavior so i think the number
one criteria i look for in a in a
relationship is that person has to be
kind they just have to be a nice person
and because eventually they'll
in a certain context you can always be
reclassified from friend to enemy
so you just want to see the boundaries
of someone's ethics if you see someone
being bad to a server or someone
engaging in unethical behavior or suing
other people or fighting other people
all the time it's only a matter of time
before they fight you so just stay away
from these high conflict people
everyone has conflict no one is clean
but that said like there are definitely
people who engage in conflict and do it
regularly and they make it a part of
their lifestyle just walk away
it's not working
there's plenty of people who are low
conflict and easy to get along with
yeah low conflict low maintenance uh who
can also be
brutally candid when necessary right
which doesn't equal eye conflict well
the one thing i've noticed and i haven't
written the tweet on this because i've
had a hard time figuring how to say it
but
the people that i want to spend time
around these days when i look at what
the common characteristic is they're
highly self-aware
they're very very aware of themselves
they're not running on autopilot they
don't get angry easily they don't get
unhappy easily
they don't take themselves too seriously
they have a certain separation from
their own thoughts and personality that
prevents circumstances and their
personality from overwhelming them they
don't have a victim mentality they're
not caught up in some story of what
happened to them when they were younger
they've had those issues for sure but
they've just gotten past them and been
like i don't want to be that person i
don't be trapped in that mindset they're
not trying to signal all the time how
important they are or who they know or
what they've done or how virtuous how
virtuous they are they're not virtue
signaling or bigoteering they have low
egos generally i can literally plot on a
line the more self-aware somebody is i
guarantee you the more attractive that
they are to a large number of people
and to into the degree that i've
achieved any modicum of fame and fame is
a trap and i'm going to pay for this i
know i will pay for this but any modicum
of fame that i've achieved
i think is because i am one of the few
people who has been successful in
business that thinks out loud in public
and because i'm willing to think out
loud in public that's a risk that i take
on it improves my thinking but other
people say oh yeah he's somewhat
self-aware he's thinking about himself
and i think that helps inspire other
people to also say okay it's okay for me
to think about myself
and i just i just find hanging around
self-aware people is a lot easier than
people who are running on autopilot
almost like npcs
npcs what does that mean non-player
characters
it's a reference to certain kinds of
video games where it's like a computer
control character right they're
predictive
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you